welcome to this video playing it you
Europe twice surprising don't remember
that name at all so let's go for a ready
system yeah in itself an opening a
clinic show on from from chest 24 yang
Gustav's on quite often gets asked about
this line with the c-4 g3 against and
you always says that he thinks that
white setup is somewhat illogical and
shouldn't lead to an advantage at the
bishop is always looking at it protected
d5 pawn like t56 well I really don't see
why this should be any worse than the
Catalan for example I mean there's also
a pawn on d5 but understand that in the
this kind of opening like this black
should have some kind of equality and so
I'm anyway there is no equality here I
ever have to be clear about that so
going g5 could have gone divorce well
I'll Quincy to which its assume this is
a tough decision as chat many alliance
here I good so the only thing that I
cannot will looked at g5 Hanks I was
thinking Quincy too but he can take g5
and then he threatens made even so i
think i'm going to develop in a way with
deform ok so he did not really think
about it for too long night on age five
is miserable really is
so can I go Queen d3 and d4 or if I
immediately if I immediately takes let's
do that takes Bishop takes is downright
awful now that's that seems fine okay
doesn't really care what I'm doing maybe
you wants to go night 97 and something
like that t Kings not yet working Queen
f3 however I can play this is even
stronger right check and that's it
threatening f7 and age 5 and the night
doesn't even have a square so it's just
a flat-out wind queen age five it's made
on h7 black resigns yeah there was a it
was this line is known to be known to be
very bad for black actually what black
has to do is to play um we should be six
year this is a lot lot better ctx Bishop
takes Knight f3 and then black and play
something like e5 and this is okay yeah
I mean flag is equal or close to being
equal but with the bishop here being
sidelined it's get very problematic here
GFI chess just one line yeah here
surprisingly you went to h5 even though
the night there's absolutely no
perspective whatsoever after de for it
has no squares here I mean it can never
be good for like now playing without the
night
if he goes to I'm here and I think the
same thing will probably happen and you
know this is just too weak before and
yeah the captures its just oh I think
the only thing that prolongs resistance
is this one Jim yeah I can even go d phi
f if I like I mean training is ok he's
playing without this night down now
that's not trading he cannot take it
because just six hangs there white wins
iam Chad yeah it's really I could have
made it I could have made it a good
chances and made checkmate okay yeah
anyway this is this is good enough it's
no way way out of this anyway check once
spied Shecky can give and then this but
check which at some kinda from chefs
will check check check check mate okay
bit longer than the immediate one but
the result is the same okay thanks for
watching